[la musique]
Formulaire ex bas à faire
quoi
Mais pourquoi as-tu peur, c'est pourquoi la lune est le seul yakuza à contrer le yakuza
[la musique]
moi
Hmm
Ana
[la musique]
moi
Hmm
Aussi, quand j'entre dans l'entreprise, je ne peux pas entrer
la
Je pense qu'il y aura plus de restrictions sociales
[la musique]
C'est vraiment de la merde, c'est en prison, c'est vraiment de la merde, c'est cintré.
C'est tellement nul
Écraser le tissu
Seule l'autosatisfaction de Maeda demeure
C'est ce que je pense maintenant
Seul
Je ne peux penser qu'à un gangster pathétique.
4 minutes
Hmm
aller
[la musique]
[applaudissements]
Regroupement soul of port security act as deki 3
Jen vérité dans le doigt à faire
aller
[la musique]
moi
[applaudissements]
Bushido bushido
Ce genre de chose est en train de se perdre
C'est en ce moment, le yakuza économique est vraiment contre ça
Je ressens la crise au Japon
[applaudissements]
[la musique]